thank you very much uh mr speaker thank
you for your words uh for your courage
and for your commitment
to peace and parliamentary uh democracy
i give the floor now to the president of
the european council charles michelle
for his statement
[Music]
[Music]
ukrainian
[Music]
[Music]
the decision
[Music]
five days ago
vladimir putin launched
a brutal
massive invasion of ukraine
an unjustified and unprovoked war
based on the speakable lies
and he did it
only for one reason
because you
dear vladimir zelente you dear people of
ukraine
in maidan
you made the choice of freedom
democracy and rule of law
and actually
it's not only ukraine
that's under attack
international law
rules-based international order
democracy
human dignity are also under attack
this is
geopolitical terrorism pure and simple
we must support ukraine and you are we
are supporting ukraine
we must protect peace we must protect
democracy and international law
and ladies and gentlemen
out in the atlantic alliance
is strong
united
perfectly coordinated
and we are also working closely with the
members of the g7
and with the united nations and more and
more countries are engaging in an
anti-war coalition along with people
from around the world with one common
message
one common message russia
stop the road go home let's torch
we are putting maximum pressure on
russia and its leaders we are stepping
up to support ukraine and the ukrainian
people i salute with all of you
president zelinski and the brave people
of ukraine for their courage and
composure
and it's also our duty to rise to this
historic moment
ladies and gentlemen
we promised together
that we would react quickly that the
consequences for russia would be massive
and severe and our actions have matched
our words we have responded with massive
and unprecedented sanctions we imposed
sanctions on political and military
leaders on holy yards on vladimir putin
on saturday lavrov we are also taking
powerful measures to severely restrict
the use of the foreign currency reserve
of the russian central bench we are
excluding key russian banks from the
swift system and
we are also
imposing
severe sanctions on key sectors of
russia's economy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
responsibility
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
m
thank you
thank you very much president uh
michelle i now give the floor to the
high representative of the union for
foreign affairs and security policy
joseph
borrel for his statement
dear members of the european parliament
i will try to
share with you my thoughts
on the meaning of the tragic events that
we are living and the provisional
lessons that we can draw
from them
especially for the
common security and defense policy
which i had the honor to try to develop
and remains
an intergovernmental policy
a policy which is
yet in the hands of the member states
but cannot be implemented efficiently
without the strong cooperation
of the commission competencies
i think this is the
the moment in which
the geopolitical europe
is being born
but
it is really the return of tragedy
to which europe is being confronted
today
to return a tragedy
far from frightening us
should galvanize us
first
because it believes the idea that the
european project had lost its momentum
because the
horizon
of the wall
has been faded
unfortunately not
this reminds us that the evil the
tragedy and the wall
never
fade away
and it's about the relationship with war
with the useless force with the violence
who have been debating here we have been
debating for years
to find out can europe can encounter it
and this is why in the recent years we
have talked more about defence issues
that in the past
and we have begun to set up joint
military programs
that's why the european parliament
itself has voted to set this european
defense fund and the member states has
created these european peace facilities
and now we are mobilizing in order to
provide arms to ukraine
european council
the networks will adopt the strategic
compass
and with the invasion of ukraine by
russia
we must amplify our reflection
adjust our means and anticipate our
responses
because one of the lessons that we have
to learn from the invasion of ukraine
is that more than ever europe must to
think strategically about itself
its environment
and the world
this is no longer a luxury it's a
necessity
europe must amplify this reflection on
security issues and european parliament
has had an important role to play in
this regard we think
we need to think about the instrument of
coercion
retaliation
and counter-attack
in the face of reckless adversaries
because all we need to understand
is that to make peace we need to be true
but to make war
is enough to be one
this is exactly what mr putin is telling
us
and that's why we have to increase our
deterring capacity a lot
we need to increase our deterrence
capacity in order to prevent war
and it's
[Applause]
and it's clear
that our deterrent has not been strong
enough
to stop mr putting aggression
but since this regression has started
we have reacted in the last few days in
a way that mr putin didn't expect
and we are showing him that we will
never sacrifice our freedom
and the freedom of others on the altar
of our well-being and prosperity
being president of this parliament in
2007
i had the opportunity to tell to mr
putin i twice
on the aftermath of the killing of a
journalist anna peryotoskaya i told him
we are not going to change human rights
by your gas
and this is the moment to repeat
and to act on that
we will not share
we will not
we will not abandon the defense of our
human rights and freedom
because we are more or less dependent on
russia and we have to start working
quickly as the commission has proposed
in order to cancel this dependency
last saturday
after having hold another foreign first
council
and attending the debate of the european
union council
i was talking with you president
michelle
and you told me
are we doing everything we can
is there something more than we can do
is that enough
how are we so
so powerless
and you told me think do act
we have to push member states in order
to adopt decision on shift and to take
russia out of the financial system think
about how can we arm
ukraine not country by country one after
all in an in coordinated manner
and you encourage me to talk with member
states again
in few hours we agreed on using this
european peace facility in order to
bring financial support and coordinate
member states on arming ukrainian army
and people
in less than 24 hours another taboo had
fallen
and the president of the commission
immediately
showing a strong leadership start
working in order to get an agreement
with our international partners in order
to make possible to switch off
russia
from the financial system and you know
what
now
half of the reserves of the central bank
of russia
are completely out of their control they
are frozen do you imagine
this is a coercion capacity
three days ago it was impossible and now
it's possible and they are start feeling
the consequences in terms of inflation
and the fall of their currency
yes we have capacities
we have mobilized these capacities
and we have to continue doing so
putting together the capacities of the
member states
and the european union i want to
remember you that the european peace
facility is not part of the budget that
you vote
is another budget it's an interventional
fund
managed by the member states
because we claim that we european union
with a peaceful force and we cannot
provide arms to anyone else
yes we can
yes we have done
on the next budget think about it
once you vote the next budget
use your budgetary capacity you have the
budgetary capacity of this institution
to put the wage means in order to face
the next crisis and the next russian
aggression
we are also working
with antennae
is
no
[Music]
much
thank you very much
thank you very much hi representative i
now give the floor to the president of
the european commission ursula von der
lion for a statement
[Applause]
madam president of the european
parliament mr president of the council
high representative
mr president of the ukraine dia
volodomir mr speaker of the ukrainian
parliament
my honorable members war has returned to
europe
almost 30 years after the balkan wars
and over half a century after soviet
troops marched into prague and budapest
civil defence sirens again went off in
the heart of a european capital
thousands of people fleeing from bombs
camped in underground stations holding
hands
crying silently trying to cheer each
other up
cars lined up towards ukrainian western
borders
and when many of them ran out of fuel
people picked up their children and
their backpacks and marched for tens of
kilometers
towards our union
they sought refuge inside our borders
because their country wasn't safe any
longer
because inside ukraine a gruesome death
count has begun
men women children are dying once again
because a foreign leader president putin
decided that their country ukraine has
no right to exist and we will never ever
let that happen and never ever accept
that
honorable members this is a moment of
truth for europe and let me quote the
editorial of one ukrainian newspaper the
kiev independent published just hours
before the invasion began and i quote
this is not just about ukraine it's a
clash of two worlds two polar set of
values
end of quote
they are so right
this is a clash between the rule of law
and the rule of the gun
between democracies
and autocracies
between a rules-based order
and a world of naked aggression
how we respond today to what russia is
doing
will determine the future of the
international system
the destiny of ukraine is at stake but
our own fate also lies in the balance
we must show the power that lies in our
democracies
we must show the power of people that
choose their independent path freely and
democratically this is our show of force
and today a union of almost half a
billion people has mobilized for ukraine
the people of europe are demonstrating
in front of russian embassies all across
our union
many of them have opened their homes to
ukrainian fleeing from putin's bombs
and let me thank specially poland
romania slovakia and hungary for
welcoming these women men and children
europe will be there for them not only
in the first days but also in the weeks
and months to come that must be our
promise altogether
[Applause]
and this is why we are proposing to
activate the temporary protection
mechanism to provide them with a secure
status and access to schools medical
care and work they deserve it we need to
do that now
and we know this is only the beginning
more ukrainians will need our protection
and solidarity we are
and we will be there for them
our union is showing a unity of purpose
that makes me proud
at the speed of light
the european union has adopted three
waves of heavy sanctions
against russia's financial system
its high-tech industries and its corrupt
elite
and this is the largest sanctions
package in our union's history
we do not take these measures lightly
but we feel we had to act
these sanctions will take a heavy toll
on the russian economy and on the
kremlin
we are disconnecting key russian banks
from the swift network
we also banned the transaction of
russia's central bank the single most
important financial institution in
russia and this paralyzes billions of
foreign reserves turning off the tap on
russia's and putin's war we have to end
this financing of this war
and second
we target important sectors of the
russian economy
we are making it impossible for russia
to upgrade its oil refineries to repair
and modernize its air fleet and to
access many important technologies it
needs to build a prosperous future we've
closed our skies to russian air club
aircraft including the private jets of
oligarchs and make no mistake
we will freeze their other assets as
well be it yachts or fancy cars or
luxury prosperities will freeze that all
together
[Applause]
and thirdly
in another unprecedented step
we're suspending the licenses of the
kremlin's propaganda machine
the state owned russia today and sputnik
and all as their and all of their
subsidiaries will no longer be able to
spread their lies on to justify putin's
war and to divide our union
and these unprecedented actions by the
european union and our partners
in response of an unprecedented
aggression by russia
each one of these steps has been closely
coordinated with our partners and allies
the united states
the united kingdom
canada and norway but also for example
japan south korea and australia
all of these days you see that more than
30 countries representing well over half
of the world's economy
have also announced sanctions and export
controls on russia
and if putin was seeking to divide the
european union to weaken nato and to
break the international community he has
achieved exactly the opposite we are
more united than ever and we will stand
up in this war that is for clear that we
will overcome and we will prevail we are
united and we stay united
[Applause]
honourable members
i am well aware that these sanctions
will come at a cost for our economy too
i know this
and i want to speak honestly to the
people of europe
we have endured two years of pandemic
and we all wished that we could focus on
our economic and social recovery
but i believe
the people of europe understand very
well
that we must stand up against this cruel
aggression
yes protecting our liberty comes at a
price
but this is a defining moment and this
is the cost we are willing to pay
because freedom is priceless honorable
members this is our principle freedom is
priceless
[Applause]
our investments today
will make us more independent tomorrow
and i'm thinking first and foremost
about our energy security
we simply cannot rely so much on a
supplier that explicitly threatens us
and this is why we reached out to other
global suppliers and they responded
norway is stepping up in january we had
the record supply of lng gas we're
building new lng terminals and working
on interconnectors
but in the long run
it is our switch to renewables and
hydrogen that will make us truly
independent
we have to accelerate the green
transition because every kilowatt hour
of electricity europe generates from
solar wind hydropower or biomass reduces
our dependency on russian gas and other
energy sources
this is a strategic investment
and my honorable members
this is a strategic investment because
on top
less dependency on russian gas and other
fossil fuel sources also means less
money for the kremlin's war chest this
is also a truth
we are resolute
europe can rise up to the challenge
the same is true on defense european
security and defense has evolved more in
the last six days than in the last two
decades
most member states have promised
deliveries of military equipment to
ukraine
germany announced that it will meet the
two percent goal of nato as soon as
possible
and our union for the first time ever
is using the european budget to purchase
and deliver military equipment to a
country that is under attack
500 million euros for the european peace
facility to support ukraine's defense
as a first batch we will now also match
this
by at least 500 million euro from the eu
budget to deal with the humanitarian
consequences of this tragic war
both in the country and for the refugees
honorable members
this is a watershed moment for our union
we cannot take our security and the
protection of people for granted
we have to stand up for it we have to
invest in it we have to carry our fair
share of the responsibility
and this crisis is changing europe
but russia has also reached
a crossroad
the actions of the kremlin are severely
damaging the long-term interests
of russia and its people
more more russians understand this as
well
they are marching for peace and freedom
and how does the kremlin respond to this
by arresting thousands of them
but ultimately
the longing for peace and freeze and
freedom cannot be silenced
there is another russia besides putin's
tanks and we extend our hand of
friendship to this other russia be
assured they have our support
honorable members
in these days independent ukraine
is facing a darkest hour
at the same time the ukrainian people
are holding up the torch of freedom for
all of us
they are showing immense courage
they are defending their lives
but they are also fighting for universal
values
and they are willing to die for them
president zielenski and the ukrainian
people are a true inspiration
and when we last spoke
he told me again about his people's
dream to join our union
today the european union and ukraine are
already closer than ever before
there's still a long path ahead
we have to end this war and we should
talk about the next steps
but i am sure
nobody in this hemi cycle can doubt
that the people that stand up so bravely
for our european values belongs in our
european family
and therefore honorable members
i say
long live europe
and long live a free and independent
ukraine
meswami slava ukraine
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much president von der
lion we